this
is one of gohan's best episodes and one
of the best episodes in dragon ball
super and it represents
everything i hate about it normally in
this series the anatomy of anime i like
to build a video around a particular
character and use that character to act
as a vehicle for exploration or
discussion around a particular narrative
technique
or archetype however as many of you
might have already noticed
i've already covered gohan so why am i
talking about him here yet again
well because in that aforementioned
video i said
this decades later with how his
character was handled and
continues to be handled today people
were really upset that i never discussed
what many considered the resurgence of
the gohan character within dragon ball
super when
in reality i didn't discuss it because
for me it was just
more of the same i'm totally not mark
and today i want to discuss what i
believe to be one of the greatest crimes
committed in this modern era of reboots
and remakes
the hollowing out of once iconic
characters
i know you have another form find me
with everything you've got
right off the bat something i want to
make perfectly clear is that gohan is a
character i adore and identified with
when i was growing up and even within
the most recent additions to the
character there are elements that i
found both thoughtful and
exhilarating there's a large portion of
gohan's fans that want him to be just
like the way he was when he faced
against cell and
i just want to distance myself from that
group first and foremost
in my last video i discussed what made
gohan's character work
and where i thought he peaked during the
cell saga but just because i believe
that to be the pinnacle for gohan's time
as a character
doesn't mean i think he should relive
those same experiences and so
keeping that in mind i think the best
way to kick this gohan video off is
with vegeta
okay let me explain vegeta much like
gohan was a brilliant and interesting
character for many of the
same reasons he was flawed produced some
terrific fights and was one of the best
character arcs in the series and still
is to this day iconic moments like a
sacrifice during the buu saga and his
acknowledgement for his loved ones and
his family
stand as some of the most memorable in
the series climaxes that were
intentionally built up too carefully
over
many years and then super did this
they repeated the exact same moment
again to
significantly less success repetition
can be a useful technique for the climax
but
not so much after this is sort of where
the phrase diminishing returns actually
comes from after the highs of the cell
saga gohan's character was never really
given a greater purpose
from the get-go he was polite and
friendly but his defining
characteristics that garnered him both
interest and fans were his
explosions of anger and after the cell
saga he couldn't depend
on that which resulted in a lot of
meandering for one reason or another
whether it be with an unearned power
boost to make him ultimate gohan
or even in super where his surprise
surprise got to relive key moments from
his younger years
but not before being thrown into the
spotlight only to be thrown
into the garbage in resurrection f
it was around this time online that a
lot of fans of gohan were really upset
and conversations surrounding the
character reached a fever pitch
and i think justifiably so with opposing
sides arguing voraciously however if
they have nothing for gohan as a
character
then sending him the way of yamcha
tenshinha and all the other side
characters
might be a good idea the spotlight
should be after all reserved for
meaningful progression of arcs and or
the plot
but super didn't do that and time
after time after time he is kept in this
strange nebulous position where he says
he's training
and improving but it almost always
happens off-screen
with any additional time we spend with
him feeling quite meaningless
and then suddenly the story starts to
care about gohan
as a character this is the section of
the story many fans will point to as the
moment gohan made a rebound as a
character and regained much of his
former glory in new
and interesting ways and to be honest i
think they're half right to be perfectly
clear
if you're someone who likes what they
did here during these latter sections of
the story i'm not about to say that
you're wrong for liking it i'm just here
to explain why i not only don't find it
great but find it to be one of the most
infuriating aspects of super's long list
of missteps and issues
but first i want to talk about something
i actually enjoyed with relatively no
reservations and that was piccolo and
gohan's fight during the tournament of
power against the universe 6 namekians
amidst the bombastic moments of the
tournament of power i sincerely felt as
though
this fight got overshadowed and
ultimately forgotten despite it being
one of the best character driven moments
in the entire series you see
one of the toughest things to deliver in
a story like dragon ball which isn't
planned out in advance is to build upon
previously successful character arcs in
both believable and meaningful ways
and that's a very difficult act to
balance if you force a character down an
interesting path
you run the risk of making it feel
artificial or forced and if you only
focus on how realistic the path
is you get a family man gohan which
while believable
wasn't very compelling to watch for me
in a show centered around conflict and i
don't envy the writers of the series at
all in this respect it's super tough
however in the anime vegeta's treatment
felt more like a novelty nostalgia act
during super
more than anything else but shockingly
those behind the story
eventually found something super
interesting
for vegeta to do interestingly as soon
as the manga surpassed the anime and
moved on to bigger and better things
vegeta became the recipient of some much
needed development that has made him
my favorite aspect of the super manga
today bouncing off of plot points rooted
deeply in his past
this new hurdle or issue vegeta needs to
overcome
has made him feel more like vegeta to me
than he has throughout all of super
wanting to atone for the sins of his
past and struggling with finding solace
in those transgressions is exactly the
sort of natural interesting progression
he
and this story needed after floundering
with the slideshow act for over 131
episodes and the crazy thing about this
is
gohan realistically wasn't nearly as
important or as prevalent of a character
during super and yet
they managed to offer gohan one of the
most interesting and natural
progressions
his character perhaps has ever received
this is one of the most interesting and
compelling plot points or arc ideas in
all of dragon ball i think dragon ball
doesn't make a habit of trying to be
profound or thought-provoking all
too often with characters like vegeta
piccolo and goku playing with concepts
like forgiveness at varying degrees and
exploring what that meant to each of
them in their positions within the world
however gohan is often in the
conversation too
boasting one of the most emphatic
coming-of-age stories in the series
however a fantastic video discussing and
exploring what gohan could possibly have
meant to us was brought to my attention
in early 2020 by
plague of gripes in it he explores the
introduction process
and fall of gohan's character through
the lens of fans that enjoyed him as an
empowerment fantasy and truth be told
this isn't a new concept it's actually
quite old but was used tremendous effect
during dragon ball to help connect young
fans to the character of gohan now i
think the gohan character has a
perfectly fine personality but
what attracted so many to him wasn't
necessarily his outward unassuming
composition but instead his ability to
flip the script on those that would try
to oppress him
and once the image of a young boy
struggling against monsters who would
underestimate and went away after cell
so too did his interest factor for
millions
so why didn't this happen with vegeta i
mean technically he lost his initial
interest factor too right
well personally i think vegeta succeeded
where gohan failed because his character
arc and development
specifically was rooted in his
relationships with other people
therefore when he tried to eventually
honestly atone for what he had done
it was cathartic yes but it also allowed
him the opportunity to explore the
character of family man vegeta which
while not super fun at least gave him
enough material to work with to warrant
being a major player
in the sequel series of super with goku
it was something new whereas gohan on
the other hand during the series
struggled to come to terms not with his
relationships but with himself
and it's great that he had this big
epiphany in the cell saga and it was
completely cathartic but
after that where does that leave him
when he inevitably has to relax as a
character
and bounce off of others the answer the
exact same place he had been before
because that epiphany he came to doesn't
really affect his relationships
all that much and certainly not the same
way vegeta's did and thus he disappeared
from the main story
until he came back the story that was
eventually offered up for gohan a
character that has almost entirely
vanished from the main plot threads
was another coming-of-age story however
this time it focused on
adulthood offering the audiences he grew
up alongside with another story or
struggle i'm sure many at some time or
another have grappled with
and that's arrogance with the best part
of this being
much like vegeta's new character act
rooted in his past gohan
now has a fitting believable and rooted
story where he must overcome the
personality flaw that has plagued him
and cost him on so many occasions in the
past a story where he must confront the
worst parts of himself to become the
stronger person
for the good of his family his friends
and himself
god i'm getting hyped just thinking
about it something like this has the
potential for being better and more
emotionally rich than the battle would
sell easily but how does super decide to
tell the story
well in short it doesn't gohan
versus goku episode 90 is one of the
best most beautiful
and most infuriatingly frustrating
episodes in
all of super's catalog for me all at the
exact same time
a phenomenal episode filled to bursting
with traditional dragon ball imagery
that looks as though it was designed
from the ground up to be the most iconic
climax to what was a long overdue story
to be told and it was frustrating
because it never received the build up
or substance a moment like this truly
deserved
which for me entirely sucked the life
out of it
for gohan in super i enjoyed his fight
with lavender i enjoyed his training
with piccolo and i enjoyed his fight
with goku however all of these take
place over the course of a few days in
the story
and a few episodes in reality making all
this time spent feel more like a
formality and leaving gohan feeling less
like a character
and more like a vessel for toei to fill
up with plot formula so that they can
use him for the tournament of power
later on
there's no time spent exploring his
mindset in any meaningful way
just a quick conversation with piccolo
who helps him find an impossibly quick
solution
and resolutions to a lifelong issue he
specifically has struggled with all
within
a single episode's b plot this could
have been one of the super anime's only
meaningful character arcs in the same
way andy and toy story 3 grew up
alongside the kids that watched toy
story 1
gohan's story could have provided a
mature and interesting exploration into
a problem
many of his older fans who grew up with
him share and they
in my opinion completely squandered it
with characters like vegeta who's had to
deal with arrogance in one way or
another
he could have offered tremendous
opportunities for conversation that
could have benefited them both
in the long term this could have given
gohan the impetus for a meaningful
change of character through natural and
believable progression
and it would have given vegeta a perfect
jumping off point for the arky would
eventually undergo
later on in super's manga with moro and
eventually granola
imagine a nuanced interesting concept
like struggling with arrogance in high
pressure situations with a mentor
character that struggled with it any
final fight against a father figure that
has found a way to float the balance
between arrogance and confidence
perfectly
to act as the final test before he must
leave his family to fight for the good
of everyone
in the most high pressure situation of
his young life
i mean it writes itself and it's
brilliant however instead of a long-term
story over the course of
months and years of struggle gohan
through a single confrontation with
piccolo
overcomes a fundamental and deeply
rooted personality flaw
all within the confines of a single
episode's b plot within dragon ball
super
making this feel less deserving and
moreover making gohan seem like an idiot
who didn't even bother trying to think
about it
at the end of the day after that dust
had settled and all the talk surrounding
my previous video came down what
surprised me the most was how readily
fans of the gohan character were willing
to accept any shine his character would
receive
as evidence of a resurgence when from my
point of view
this was only further evidence to the
contrary i adore gohan as a character
and like all of you watching his high
points in the series offer me some of
the most iconic and enjoyable from my
childhood
however as i hope i explained in this
video superficial window dressing
isn't enough to grant substance to a
character that has been bankrupt of
substance
in my opinion for an unjustified amount
of time all i have to do
is point to characters like piccolo
junior's introduction and his sacrifice
for gohan or
vegeta's ruthless lone wolf persona and
his eventual sacrifice in defense of
those he built relationships with to
show you all
what the benefit of time and thought
gives to a particular moment
it gives it substance it gives it weight
it makes
it meaningful and until such time
gohan's character receives that
he will unfortunately remain a hollow
character thanks for watching
run